Oberyn Martell: For centuries, the Iron Throne
had no more loyal ally than the Princes of
Dorne.
Since the Martells had never fallen to them,
we kept our ancestral title.
Perhaps this is what drew Rhaegar Targaryen
to us.
His royal parents had not produced a sister
for him to wed, so he had to look elsewhere
for a princess, and there was only one in
Westeros.
Elia of House Martell, my sister.
She was not the most beautiful woman in the
world or even in Dorne.
But, rare for a woman from our land, her flower
came with no thorns.
She was kind and clever with a gentle heart.
I loved her.
I feared for her.
For years, I fended off lesser men from her.
But when Rhaegar came, even I failed.
He was beautiful, and the crown prince of
the Seven Kingdoms.
And our mother had worked so hard to secure
the match.
How could Elia not accept it?
They were wed, and he took Elia from her home,
from those who loved her and would die for
her and locked her in his Red Keep above his
sty of a city surrounded by false friends.
She bore him a daughter and a son, though
each almost cost her her life.
Elia loved Rhaegar, she obeyed him, and he
chose to steal away Lyanna Stark, a pale northern
girl whose veins ran with ice like all of
her people.
Instead of disciplining his faithless son,
King Aerys executed the Starks when they came
seeking justice and ignited a revolt.
I know how the maesters describe the war now
but calling it "Robert's Rebellion" does not
change what it was.
The War of the Usurper.
Dorne sided with the Crown, for when we swear
oaths, we keep them.
We needed no threats from King Aerys, though
he made them anyway, locking Elia and her
children in the Red Keep to ensure our loyalty.
Even in his madness, he knew that no true
Dornishman would ever take up arms against
our beloved princess and that we would fight
to the death for whatever side she was on.
Barristan Selmy: A plan was devised; Prince
Rhaegar would personally lead the royal forces,
now reinforced with ten thousand Dornishmen,
north to face Robert, while the Kingsguard,
Lewyn Martell and I, would ride with the prince.
Oberyn Martell: At the Trident, Dorne lost
ten thousand men and two princes.
My uncle in the Kingsguard and Elia's gallant
husband Prince Rhaegar, who was too slow or
too arrogant for Robert's war hammer.
As Robert's army marched on King's Landing,
the Mad King sent his own wife and child away
but kept my sister and hers inside.
In his madness, Aerys thought the Dornish
had betrayed his son at the Trident and was
only too happy to welcome his one true friend
back into his ranks.
Tywin Lannister.
Lord Tywin's army sacked his friend's city
while Lord Tywin's son murdered the king he
had sworn to protect.
All of this could have been forgiven.
War is terrible, and men must become terrible
to wage it.
But the Lannisters knew that as long as Elia
and her children, Prince Rhaegar's heirs,
lived, no usurper could safely sit the Throne.
So Lord Tywin's dog, "Ser" Gregor Clegane,
the Mountain, made Elia watch as he murdered
her daughter and dashed her infant son's head
against a wall.
Then with her baby's blood still on his hands,
he murdered her.
When Lord Tywin later presented their bodies
to Robert Baratheon wrapped in pretty Lannister
cloaks, I have been told the red color graciously
hid the blood from men's eyes.
The Targaryens talk of fire and blood.
In Dorne, our blood is fire.
If Robert Baratheon had dared set foot in
Dorne during his reign, he would have lost
the foot.
When I was a boy of sixteen, a great lord
caught me with his mistress.
He should have been honored.
Instead, the fat old fool challenged me to
a duel.
Thanks to my age and status, only to first
blood.
But his mistress, and his wife, warned me
which of my parts he intended to draw first
blood from.
He was strong and fierce but slow.
I cut him quickly, and the duel ended with
honor satisfied.
Then, his wounds festered, and he died.
Ever since, men have called me "the Red Viper,"
a name that never fails to draw a laugh from
me.
As if a single serpent was all he knew of
venom.
Varys: Westeros has mighty rivers, but none
of them compare to the Rhoyne.
It is said that there is no stream or puddle
in western Essos but drains to Mother Rhoyne.
No doubt, an exaggeration.Until one sees the
river.
At its widest, a man in the center can't see
a shore to either side.
The greatest of Mother Rhoyne's children were
the Rhoynar, a civilization as ancient and
grand as Old Ghis.
Fishers, traders, scholars, workers of wood,
stone, and metal, the Rhoynar raised their
elegant cities from the headwaters of the
Rhoyne down to her mouth, each lovelier than
the last.
For many centuries, the Rhoynar lived in relative
peace.
When invaders swept down from the hills, the
Rhoynar women and men would don silver-scaled
armor, fish head helms, tall spears, and turtle
shell shields.
If the enemy did not laugh themselves away,
it was said that Mother Rhoyne would whisper
the enemy's secrets to her children, and the
Rhoynish wizards could raise watery walls
to drown their foes.
Whatever magic the Rhoynar may have had, it
wasn't enough.
When Valyrian colonists first arrived, the
Rhoynar embraced them, for all men were welcome
to share the bounty of Mother Rhoyne.
Perhaps a water people should have been more
cautious of strangers who exulted fire and
blood.
Legend has it that one day the Valyrians netted
and butchered one of the giant turtles the
Rhoynar held sacred.
As a result, thousands were killed or enslaved,
cities and towns were burned, drowned, and
rebuilt.
In these wars, the Valyrians emerged as victorious
more often than not.
The princes of the Rhoynish cities, fiercely
proud of their independence, fought alone,
whilst the Valyrian colonies aided one another.
Eventually, the Rhoynish princes ceased their
squabbling and united behind Prince Garin,
who led the largest army Essos had ever seen
against 100,000 Valyrian colonists, 100 war
elephants, and three dragonlords.
Thousands burned, but thousands more sheltered
in the shallows of the river whilst the Rhoynish
wizards raised enormous water spouts against
the foes' dragons.
Rhoynish archers brought down two of the dragons
whilst the third fled wounded, and thereafter
the Rhoynar named Garin "the Great."
But Mother Valyria proved just as caring as
Mother Rhoyne.
When Garin the Great marched his army against
Volantis, three hundred Valyrian dragons descended
from the sky.
Tens of thousands burned whilst others rushed
into the river.
But the fire burned so hot that the waters
boiled and turned to steam.
Garin the Great was captured alive and made
to watch as Valyrians butchered every last
man, so many that their blood turned the great
harbor of Volantis red as far as the eye could
see.
Then they forced Garin to watch as they marched
on his own city and enslaved all the women
and children his army had left behind.
The singers claimed that Prince Garin called
out Mother Rhoyne to curse the Valyrians,
and she, in turn, flooded the city with foul
waters and a damp fog that caused the skin
of the Valyrians to harden and crack, and
thus was born greyscale.
Fearing a similar fate, another Rhoynish ruler,
Princess Nymeria, led her own people into
every ship, skiff, and raft they had and fled
Essos.
Eventually, after much hardship, they landed
in sunswept and bone dry Dorne.
But we all know that tale.
Oberyn Martell: She was lucky to land in Dorne,
where powerful women are not locked away in
septs and the beds of old men.
My ancestor, Mors Martell, saw her and desired
her, and proved that where armies fail, a
tongue may succeed.
Wedding his strength to hers, his spear to
her sun, they subdued all of his rivals together.
After the tradition of her people, House Martell
then ruled Dorne as Princes, not kings, unless
the eldest child was a daughter.
For unlike the rest of Westeros, our loyalty
is not commanded by a cock.
We follow a Prince or a Princess Martell just
the same, and we always have.
Some people forget that Aegon Targaryen crowned
himself lord of six kingdoms, not seven.
When his sister marched on Dorne, she found
no mighty hosts drawn up against her for her
dragon to burn and her soldiers to slaughter.
The sands swirled, men died, and her dragon
saw nothing.
The sun shone, men died, and her dragon bowed
to our greater fire.
The Targaryens retreated with their tails
tucked between their legs.
Of course, in later years, his descendants
would try again.
Daeron the First succeeded at great cost and
reigned in Dorne for a few glorious months.
One night, his steward pulled down a sash
by his bed to summon his consorts.
Instead, the canopy split open, and a hundred
red scorpions fell on him.
He was a Tyrell.
You would think he would be used to getting
stung.
Within a fortnight, House Martell again ruled
a free Dorne.